Haben wir dann eigentlich den Einspieler an den Gehen?
Den mache ich im Schnitt hinterher.
Alles klar.
Ich kann den auch singen. Hat jemand eine Ukulele?
Ja, herzlich willkommen, liebe Zuhörer bei Akronomisierbar Folge 26.
zumindest sind wir wieder auf dem
Chaos Communication Kongress in Leipzig
diesmal machen wir einen kleinen
Jahresrückblick, das ist quasi die akronisierbar
Featuring Penta Radio
Jahresrückblick
Skala und wir haben sehr viele Gäste
wir haben ein Live-Publikum
wir haben Musik, wir haben Tänzer
alles ist vorhanden
nee, wir sind eigentlich tatsächlich relativ viele Leute
am Tisch, können wir uns mal ganz kurz vorstellen
also hi, ich bin der Hendrik und wer seid ihr?
ja, ich bin der Jules
Hi Jules
Hi Hendrik
Läuft schon, läuft schon
Ja, wir kennen uns schon ganz schön lange
sehen uns aber nicht mehr so oft
Das Meme ist eigentlich, dass Kilian
dich nicht kennt und auch nicht weiß, wer du bist
Obwohl wir uns eigentlich kennen
Ich kenne ihn nämlich
Der andere rothaarige Typ
Schön, dass du mal dabei bist, du kannst hoffentlich auch sehr viel
Interessantes zu erzählen
Neben dir sitzt eine sehr bekannte
Stimme in unserer Sendung
Hallo, ich bin der Steiger, ich habe mich auch auf den Kongress
Sehr schön.
Und ich glaube, da muss ich jetzt nicht mehr viel dazu sagen.
Nee, Steiger kennt man mittlerweile.
Steiger kennt man.
Eine bekannte Marke.
Hallo an alle.
Zum ersten Mal in dieser Sendung ist der Stefan mir gegenüber.
Genau, also in meinem Personalausweis steht Stefan und mein Nickname ist Xyrel oder Xyril,
je nachdem, ob man es Deutsch oder Englisch aussprechen möchte.
Und ich bin quasi der Ideengeber gewesen hierfür, weil ich wollte eigentlich fürs Penta-Radio
einen Jahresrückblick machen, aber dann war ich leider irgendwie zu beschäftigt, schräg,
faul, das dann vorzubereiten.
Und dann dachte ich hier, lasse ich das einfach
andere Leute machen. Das lasse ich einfach den Hendrik
hier den Termin reservieren im Sendezentrum.
Ja, ich habe den Termin reserviert.
Ich habe es auf Twitter verbreitet. Ich habe das Pad angefangen.
Ja, alles. Sehr gut, es umgelabelt.
Jahresrückblick, S is Service.
Ich wollte schon immer mal was mit dem Pentacast.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eigentlich schon fast ein Sendungstitel.
Das ist das
J-A-A-S.
Gut, okay. Eine Person gibt es noch
in der Runde. Ja, hi, ich bin Marius.
Du warst auch schon mal
In welcher Folge war es nochmal?
Ich bin schlecht mit unserem Folgen.
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall
über funktionale Programmierung viel geredet.
Unschuldiges Programmieren?
Ja, genau. Das war es.
Das ist immer witzig, wenn man plötzlich ein Gesicht dazu hat.
Formale Methoden und solche Sachen.
Sehr gut.
Ja, also 2018
nähert sich dem Ende.
Wir haben den 29. Dezember, an dem man
Du sollst doch nicht das Datum der Aufnahme verraten.
Ich blieb das dann aus.
Nein, wir sind auf dem Kongress.
Das wird einer dieser drei, vier Tage gewesen sein.
Genau.
Und ich meine, was ist dann,
wie hat denn dieses Jahr für uns angefangen?
Also ich rede ja mal aus der Perspektive für akronomisierbar.
Einige von euch hören es ja.
Gefühlt hat es ja angefangen exakt vor einem Jahr auf dem Kongress,
etwa zehn Meter von hier entfernt an dieser Stelle.
Das letzte Mal war der Sendetisch ein bisschen woanders.
Da haben wir eine Koop mit HelloSwift gemacht,
den zwei Leuten aus Berlin.
das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht
auf jeden Fall, da war Kira noch mit dabei
und seitdem haben wir eigentlich dieses Jahr
extrem viele Folgen mit Gästen
und Interviews gemacht, also ich zähle mal auf
wen wir alles hatten, wir hatten den Marius zu Gast
wir hatten Jupp zu Gast
wir hatten Johannes zu Gast, wir hatten
Florian Gilcher vom Rustfest zu Gast
und wir hatten
Henrik von Mozilla zu Gast
wir haben über extrem viele Programmiersprachen geredet
dieses Jahr, um mal einige aufzuzählen
es waren dabei Reason, Zig
Haskell, Huck, Idris
F-Star, Akda, Daphne
Silt, Typescript, Go
Ada und noch einige
ESO-Lengs, die der Kilian auch nochmal zusammengetragen
hatte. Ich muss sagen, für unsere Sendung, dafür,
dass wir ein bisschen weniger Folgen gemacht haben,
war es ein sehr bewegtes Jahr.
Größte Änderung ist, dass Kilian zur Zeit
nicht da ist, aber er hört uns offenbar gerade
live zu, habe ich den Eindruck. Der schreibt nämlich
hier gerade.
Was? Ich kenne Jules nicht, das stimmt gerade.
Jetzt erinnert er sich. Plötzlich.
Was ist denn für euch so dieses Jahr passiert?
Ja, wir hatten auch jede Menge Folgen
bei Penta Radio. Also ich weiß ja nicht,
wie ich Penta Radio jetzt erklären muss für die
Akronomisierbar-Hörer, aber du hast ja auch Akronomisierbar
nicht für die Penta Radio-Hörer erklärt.
Also das Penta Radio ist der
alteingesessene Podcast
des C3D2 aus der nächsten.
Das ist ja bitteschön eine Radiosendung. Wir sind tatsächlich
auf dem Äther live.
Stimmt. Und dann
muss irgendwo, ist ein PC
von Honky, der dann
den Livestream dann abgreift
und dann halt wegspeichert live.
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert, was wohl
meines Wissens nach dem Februar der Fall war, dann haben wir auch
keinen Podcast davon, weil es einfach
keine Aufzeichnung gibt. Mittlerweile
haben wir, glaube ich, zwei Rechner, die das machen, so als
High Availability Szenario.
Sehr gut.
Irgendwann wird das Radiosignal von einem fernen Stern
reflektiert werden und dann kommt es wieder auf der Erde an.
Naja, sei es drum.
Jetzt habe ich schon wieder gemacht,
was ich immer mache. Ich gehe auf Tangenten.
Denn das ist natürlich eigentlich nicht, was die Frage beantworten sollte.
Und zwar das Penta Radio ist einfach die monatliche Radiosendung vom Chaos Computer Club Dresden.
Und das ist eine Phrase, die habe ich jetzt schon sehr oft gesagt.
Deswegen kann ich Chaos Computer Club Dresden auch relativ unfallfrei mittlerweile sagen.
Chaos Computer Club Dresden?
Ja, das ist sehr leicht, sich dazu verhaspeln.
Und da machen wir jeden vierten Dienstag im Monat von 21.30 Uhr bis 23 Uhr.
Und das hört man im Radio auf Coloradio.
Und dann mit einer ungefähr ähnlichen Geschwindigkeit, wie das auch akronomisierbar ist,
kann man sich leicht verhasteln.
Wie das auch akronomisierbar der Fall ist, kommen dann die Folgen irgendwann so innerhalb der nächsten,
ja, vielleicht gerade so vor der nächsten Sendung dann auch auf die Webseite.
Sehr cool.
Also ich höre auf jeden Fall auch PETA-Radio hin und wieder.
Und das ist eines der Vorbilder für unseren Podcast gewesen.
Oh, sehr schön.
Also ich muss sagen, ein Kritikpunkt, den ich häufig bei Penta-Radio-Folgen hatte,
ich war ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal dabei,
manchmal, wenn man so mittendrin einsteigt und nicht die vorherigen Sendungen hört,
fragt man sich, wer sind diese ganzen Stimmen,
wie viele Leute sitzen da im Raum und wer ist das alles,
weil sich manchmal die Leute gar nicht vorstellen.
Also zumindest in den Folgen, in denen ich jetzt beteiligt war,
haben wir das eigentlich immer gemacht.
Sehr gut.
Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe da nicht das ganze Backlog irgendwie gehört.
Also ich arbeite mich jetzt zur Zeit in meiner Podcast-App durch Akronomisierbar durch.
Aber da habe ich auch noch ein bisschen was zu tun.
Da bin ich irgendwie so in der Mitte des Jahres 2018 gerade oder so.
Und vom Penta-Radio kenne ich hauptsächlich die Folgen, an denen ich tatsächlich selber mitgewirkt habe in irgendeiner Form.
Und das fängt so im Juni an.
Was ist denn im Penta-Radio dieses Jahres bis jetzt?
Ja, wir hatten im Januar eine interessante Folge, die ja auch bei euch Erwähnung gefunden hat,
zu Spectrum, Meltdown, das goldene Zeitalter der CPU-Verwundbarkeiten.
wo ja auch einige der Leute zu Gast waren,
die an der Entdeckung dieser Lücken
beteiligt waren. Sehr gute Folge, kann ich noch empfehlen.
Was hatten wir noch?
Natürlich ging es
um Datenschutz relativ viel.
Im März hatten wir Cambridge Analytica,
im Mai natürlich die Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Jetzt raste aber durch dieses Jahr durch.
Wir müssen ja auch irgendwie hier das Ganze
in einer endlichen Zeit
in die Bühne bekommen.
Wir hatten zwei Folgen zu den Datenspuren,
einmal davor, einmal danach. Wir hatten
ja so ein paar gemischte Themen.
ich glaube April war hier, wie eigentlich
der Bootprozess unter Linux funktioniert, also
Unix, Linux, Debian,
Ubuntu, wo dann auch so ein bisschen
Ubuntu noch erklärt wurde.
Ich habe zwei Folgen gemacht,
zwei Themen, einmal Cloud Computing, was ich so auf Arbeit
mache und habe, das war so meine
erste richtige Erfahrung mit Radio sein
und ich habe festgestellt irgendwie, dass
ich hatte mir so ein Programm vorbereitet,
weil ich dachte, ah, vielleicht könnte man damit so eine Stunde
voll kriegen und ich war nach einer Stunde
zum Drittel durch.
So ist es bei Vorträgen.
Um mal mit einer Frage gleich einzuhacken
und mitten ins Jahr zu gehen.
Wie waren denn die Datenspuren?
Ich habe es dieses Jahr leider gar nicht geschafft,
weil ich an dem Tag
Bier brauen musste.
Bier? Du arme Sau, ey.
Wie hat das eigentlich geklappt?
Schmeckt sehr, sehr geil.
Wie viel schafft man?
Und warum hast du keins mit?
Ja, eben.
Ja, weil ich eine etwas
längere und kompliziertere Anreise hier zum
Kongress hatte und nicht unendlich
viel Gepäck mitbringen konnte.
Also die heutige Folge wird nicht
gesponsert von Jumil Bier,
gesponsert von Clubmate und Premium-Cola,
wie ich sehe. Und Flora Power.
Darf ich mal wieder erwähnen, dass die
Flora Power auf dem Kongress, wer noch nicht auf dem Kongress
mal eine Flora Power getrunken hat, eigene
Labels für den Kongress druckt.
Mit der Fairy Dust vorne drauf.
Sehr schick. Aber ich finde es ja immer noch
schade, dass es keine Kohle Mate gibt hier.
Es wäre irgendwie was Lokales.
Es gibt einen Stand, da habe ich schon eine gekauft.
Es gibt so eine kleine...
Ja, aber 3 Euro für eine 0,33er.
Das ist krass, dann.
Wo ist eigentlich Fairy Dust?
Ich habe Fairy Dust noch nicht gesehen.
Das habe ich mich auch schon gefragt.
Wie, habt ihr echt noch nicht gesehen?
Nee.
Na, hinten ist doch, wie heißt das denn, diese Partyhalle?
Frenn-Halle 5.
Demo-Drama, äh, Disco-Drama.
Disco-Drama.
Ach, stimmt, da steht die.
Dort steht sie.
Ach so, das ist dann vorbei.
Sieht ziemlich cool aus sogar, finde ich.
Da gehe ich aus Erfahrung nicht rein,
weil da kriege ich immer tränende Augen,
wenn ich da reingehe.
Nee, ist ja nicht Hamburg.
Also du brauchst hier nicht rauchen.
So in Hamburg hatte ich da diese Disco, da bin ich irgendwie einmal reingegangen
und dann hatte ich halt irgendwie festgestellt, da werden legale Drogen etc. konsumiert.
Nein, nein.
Dann bin ich wieder rausgegangen, weil es dann auch relativ schnell, wie gesagt,
und ich bin ja mit der Allergie auch ein bisschen empfindlich.
So, jetzt hatten wir, wie viele Tangenten hatten wir jetzt?
Wir sind auf die Mate gekommen durch das Bier, durch die Datenspuren.
Die Datenspuren.
Bleiben wir auf die Datenspur.
Wir waren ja diesmal jetzt das erste Mal im Zentralwerk, also in der Kulturgenossenschaft,
wo auch der Chaos Computer Club Dresden seinen Sitz hat.
Und das war auf jeden Fall eine völlig andere Stimmung als der technischen Sammlung.
Ich meine, die technische Sammlung ist halt ein Museum mit täglichem Betrieb.
Das ist alles professionell gemacht, ein bisschen verwinkelt für meinen Geschmack.
Und das Zentralwerk wirkt alles noch sehr unfertig, denn dieser Veranstaltungssaal,
in dem da die Hauptvortragsreihe lief und wo auch die Bar war und so weiter.
Und viele der Kunstinstallationen, die ist halt noch im Bauzustand.
Die ist auch noch nicht tatsächlich als Veranstaltungsort genehmigt.
Da muss man immer Einzelgenehmigungen sich holen.
Aber das wird sich hoffentlich bis nächstes Jahr dann ändern,
denn es gab dieses Jahr da auch eine erfolgreiche Crowdfunding-Kampagne,
bei der ich auch mitgespendet habe, beziehungsweise einen Perk gekauft habe sozusagen.
Da ging es darum, dass die Klimaanlage...
Da muss eine Lüftungsanlage rein in das Ding.
Und das kostet anscheinend wie 120.000 oder so, so eine Lüftungsanlage für einen Veranstaltungssaal einzubauen.
Sind aber zusammengekommen, richtig?
Und vieles davon ist halt Förderung, aber so eine Förderung ist ja immer davon abhängig, dass du auch deinen eigenen Teil aufbringst.
Und der wurde durch dieses Crowdfunding gemacht.
Das waren 30.000 für heiße Luft, hieß die Kampagne.
Und es ist auch zusammengekommen.
Es sah ein bisschen bedenklich aus für mich.
Also es waren wie ein paar Tage vorher, hatten noch 10.000 gefehlt.
Aber es hat irgendwie dann tatsächlich doch geklappt.
Es hat irgendwie Erwähnung gefunden bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Vielleicht könnte man mal die Korrelation zu der Veröffentlichung von dieser Folge,
wo es erwähnt wurde und wo plötzlich die Spenden reingekommen sind.
Gut, ich habe jetzt nicht die Daten von Startnext.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht überprüfen, aber das könnten die vielleicht in ihrer Telemetrie sehen.
Ja, und ich hatte auch mehr als Perk eine Architektenführung ausgewählt,
weil es gab meistens Kunstwerke, die halt von den ganzen Ateliers in dem Gebäude gesponsert wurden.
Und das ist jetzt nicht so meins.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt keine künstlerisch anspruchsvolle Wohnung.
Und dann jetzt irgendwie...
Ich habe jetzt auch kein Interesse,
eine Sammlung anzufangen.
Und dann ist es ja auch blöd, ein Kunstwerk zu haben.
Das sieht ja dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen out of place aus.
Und deswegen habe ich dann die Architektenführung genommen.
Und das war richtig interessant,
weil das war früher,
bevor es diese Kulturgenossenschaft gekauft hat,
hat es der Sächsischen Zeitung gehört,
weil es früher zum VEB-Grafik-Großbetrieb-Völkerfreundschaft gehörte.
Das habe ich jetzt garantiert irgendwas falsch gesagt davon.
Und vor dem Krieg war es eine Munitionsfabrik.
Also total bewegte Geschichte.
Und weil es zu diesem Grafikgroßpolitik gehörte,
war da auch viel Druck, was da gemacht wurde.
Also schon ein Kappmaschinen im Keller,
der Chaos Computer Club auch drin ist unter anderem.
Und da ist der Boden extrem kontaminiert.
Also da waren gigantische Kosten angefallen,
einfach dafür Altlasten zu entsorgen
und das Gebäude überhaupt irgendwie bewohnbar zu machen.
Also was bei mir an den Datenspuren so ein bisschen hängen geblieben ist,
ist, dass es zur Hälfte im Freien war
und dass dieser Vortragssaal halt wirklich sehr, sehr unfertig war.
Das ist so ein bisschen,
es hat ja auch die ganze Zeit geschifft.
Das heißt, man ist da irgendwie von dem einen Raum rüber
unter so ein Zelt in den anderen Raum gerannt.
Das war so ein bisschen ungünstig.
Die technischen Sammlung habe ich in dem Moment so ein bisschen vermisst.
Da hat man zwar sehr viel Cardiotraining gemacht,
weil man den ganzen Tag zwischen fünf Stockwerken
Treppe hoch und Treppe runter gerannt ist.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wie es nächstes Jahr aussieht.
und kann definitiv den Entwicklungsgrad des CCC Dresden dabei sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Also nächstes Jahr wird der Veranstaltungsdauer auf jeden Fall ein bisschen schöner sein.
Nächstes Jahr werden auch womöglich schon Aufzüge in den Gebäuden drin sein.
Also aufgrund dieser vielen Kosten für die Altlasten wurde der behindergerechte Ausbau zurückgestellt.
Aber das muss jetzt halt kommen, weil das ja eine Bedingung ist für die Wohnbauförderung, die es da gab.
Also da wird es auf jeden Fall einiges geben.
Das können wir dann im Jahresrückblick 2019 besprechen.
Also ich persönlich fand eigentlich die Raumgestaltung sehr cool.
Es hat so einen industrial Style gehabt.
Das hat mich nicht gestört, dass es so ein bisschen unfertig war,
aber dieses halb draußen, das stimmte schon.
Das ist halt einfach, wenn es kalt und regnerisch ist,
dann ist es blöd, wenn einfach das Meet and Greet und die Basteltische und die Workshop-Sachen,
wenn die draußen stattfinden.
Das war halt nicht gerade ein Sommerfest in dem Moment.
Nee, absolut nicht. Also September, Oktober, September glaube ich. Da kann theoretisch auch noch gutes Wetter sein, war es aber halt nicht.
Ja, 29. September, also 29. September glaube ich.
Und was mir dieses Jahr auch aufgefallen ist, was ich persönlich cool fand, aber auch wieder nicht so cool, weil andere Leute so aus meinem Umfeld halt nicht so ihren Platz gefunden haben in den Datenspuren, was schon sehr technisch war.
Stimmt, also die Datenspuren die Jahre davor,
ihr hattet immer noch so ein bisschen politischere Themen oder so Kunstthemen.
Das war diesmal eine fast komplett ausschließlich technische Veranstaltung.
Also ich fand es cool, aber so die letzten Jahre habe ich halt immer auch mal
wenigstens einen meiner Mitbewohner dazu gekriegt, mitzukommen.
Das war diesmal irgendwie nicht so möglich.
Das müssen wir im nächsten Jahr mal überdenken,
ob man nicht wieder noch ein paar andere Themen da mit reinbringen kann.
Aber grundsätzlich ziemlich schön, dass jetzt mal so der Dresdner CCC und seine Konferenz sozusagen an einem Ort sind, finde ich eine schöne Veranstaltung.
Jetzt sind wir im Jahr schon so ein bisschen hin und her gehopst. Wie wollen wir es denn machen? Wollen wir ein bisschen chronologisch durchgehen?
Also ich würde sagen, wenn wir jetzt schon die Datenspuren hatten, dann würde ich jetzt gleich mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, um mal abzufragen, was denn eure Höhepunkte auf dem Kongress gerade sind.
Ja, dann...
Wer möchte anfangen?
Wer hat noch nichts gesagt heute?
Da wäre ich jetzt wohl dran.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen
zurückgehalten mit
Besuchen von Talks.
Man sieht dich fast gar nicht.
Ja, ich
netzweige im Seabase
Assembly
und habe aber gestern ein paar Talks
mitgenommen. Da war zum Beispiel einer dabei,
da ging es mal um eine
Ich sage mal, wissenschaftliche Betrachtung, wie Bewusstsein entsteht,
gerade im Kontext von den künstlichen Intelligenzen.
Gerscherbach oder?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Der gefiel mir sehr gut, den muss ich mir aber nochmal reinziehen.
Klingt nach Gerscherbach?
Ja, von ihm habe ich auch letztens einen Podcast gehört von Alternativlos, glaube ich, war das.
Den kann ich auch sehr, sehr empfehlen.
Auch schon getan.
Da gibst du uns am besten mal die Links für die Shownotes,
damit die Leute, die das jetzt hören, was haben Sie mit draufklicken.
und am ersten Tag war auch mal ein netter Talk zum Beispiel über TLS 1.3,
das ja auch dieses Jahr erschienen oder fertiggestellt wurden.
Stimmt, da saß es nicht zusammen drin, da habe ich erst gedacht,
oh, das wird jetzt wieder so eine Krypto-Vorlesung.
Aber der wurde dann tatsächlich ziemlich gut,
weil er die Entwicklungsgeschichte der Standardisierung von dem Protokoll durchgenommen hat.
Ich habe mich jetzt mit der Person nicht direkt auseinandergesetzt, wer das genau war,
es wirkte euch nicht so, als wenn er wirklich bei der IETF
mit bei der Stellarisierung
zu Gange war und hat dann mal
so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen geplaudert
und dort schön
ein über Enterprise Software
abgelassen, zu Recht
und naja,
ist so ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel.
Genau, aber dann kann ich auch mal weitergeben.
Ja, genau, ich gucke gerade schon.
Also ich fand gestern
ja,
Vormittag, sage ich mal,
A Farewell-to-Soul-Crushing-Code eigentlich ganz schön.
Ist jetzt nicht so mein absolutes Highlight.
Ich fand es aber sehr, sehr schön,
dass es mal eine gute Argumentation für funktionale Programmierung
abseits dieser üblichen Überzeugungsargumente brachte.
Kannst du es kurz zusammenfassen?
Sie haben viele Code-Beispiele.
Es waren zwei Consultants, die wohl viel in Projekten unterwegs sind.
haben viele Codebeispiele aus OOP-Projekten und sonst sowas gebracht,
wo du einfach unglaublich schlecht strukturierten Code gesehen hast.
Sind so ein bisschen auf die konzeptuellen Schwachstellen eingegangen.
Zum Beispiel, dass eben eine Objektorientierung, sie versucht ja irgendwie die reale Welt nachzubilden,
aber hat dabei ja auch gewisse Lücken.
Hat so eine schöne Folie, ein Elefant verlässt den Dschungel und geht in einen Raum.
Was tut der? Der ist im Dschungel, geht durch eine Tür und ist dann in diesem Raum.
Das ist ja ein fließender Übergang.
Der verschwindet nicht irgendwie aus dem Dschungel und poppt dann in diesem Raum auf.
Bilde ich dieses Problem aber irgendwie in der Programmierung mit Objekten ab.
Dann nehme ich den Elefanten aus dem Dschungel raus.
Zack, dann ist er weg.
Und dann zack, tue ich ihn in diesen Raum.
Und so haben sie sich ein bisschen rangearbeitet.
an die funktionalen Aspekte und haben dann auch am Beispiel
des Fertigungsprozesses in einer Chipfabrik so ein bisschen
demonstriert, naja, wie kannst du sinnvoll
funktionale Software strukturieren und aufbauen. Fand ich sehr gut gemacht.
Und was war jetzt nicht nur Objekteorientierung
gegen funktionale Programmierung? Nö, ging so auch allgemein ein bisschen
ein paar Konzepte, die ganz schön sind.
Ja, was ich schön fand dieses Jahr,
ist, dass sie an einigen Stellen angefangen haben,
einfach Vorträge mit aufzunehmen, die so Basics
von bestimmten Sachen erklären.
Ja, das fand ich auch toll.
Weil so ein bisschen der Vorruf im Raum stand,
viele Leute gehen hier nicht gerne hin, weil
sie sind ja nur die Experten in den Themen und die ganzen Vorträge
sind alle ziemlich...
Da fand ich sehr schön,
Layman's Guide to Zero-Day Engineering.
Fand ich auch echt
in vielerlei Hinsicht überraschend,
weil sie eben echt auch gesagt haben,
hey Leute, also natürlich ist das
mega kompliziert, aber sie sind
sehr viel drauf eingegangen, so naja, eigentlich
versuchen wir so blöd wie möglich an die Sache
ranzugehen, um es uns selbst einfach zu machen.
Also Zero-Day-Engineering
heißt, wie finde ich ein Zero-Day?
Und wie baue ich einen Export dafür?
Genau.
Genau, und ansonsten hast du halt immer
wieder großartige Talks,
auch aus dem gesellschaftlichen Umfeld.
Also
Frag den Staat ist ja jedes Jahr
finde ich ein sehr schöner Talk.
Den zum BAMF gestern
auch ziemlich gut.
Weiß aber nicht mehr, was da dein Titel war.
Da bin ich eher zufällig
reingerutscht. Algorithmen, die über Asyl entscheiden.
Genau, ja.
Also es ist natürlich wieder sehr schockierend.
Das war wieder so ein
Vortrag aus dem Umfeld Logbuch
Netzpolitik. Ja, ja, ja.
Sie sind immer ausgezeichnet.
Ja.
Also ich war in einem Vortrag, der komplett
atypisch war, zumindest thematisch.
Und zwar
Sex. Und zwar ging es dabei nicht wirklich um Sex, sondern es ging halt dabei um das Geschlecht.
Und dass bei Medizin und bei der Medizinforschung und der Medizinanwendung das Geschlecht von Personen grundlegend ignoriert wurde in den letzten Jahren,
du findest sehr viele Textbuchbeispiele zum Thema Symptome von Herzattacken oder Behandlungen oder sowas immer nur am Beispiel von Männern.
Textbücher sind voll mit schematischen Zeichnungen, es sind immer nur Männer.
Und zum Beispiel die Symptome von Herzattacken sind bei Männern ganz andere als bei Frauen, interessanterweise.
Und das sind Sachen, die kann ich jetzt nicht eins zu eins wiedergeben,
aber die sind in dem Talk sehr, sehr gut zusammengefasst worden.
Es gab einen ziemlich schönen Überblick darüber, wie diese ganze Sparte vernachlässigt wurde.
Und eines der Probleme ist ja auch, dass die Forschung vornehmlich von Männern betrieben wird.
Und wenn man anspricht, kann man nicht mal mehr die Perspektive der Frau beleuchten.
und sowas wie, ja, es sind doch alle gleich.
So ein schwieriges Thema.
Aber ich fand diesen Talk sehr spannend.
Kann ich an dieser Stelle mal empfehlen.
Marius, kannst du deinen Talk empfehlen?
Ja, aber ich kann auch nicht nur Talks empfehlen.
Also für mich ist tatsächlich irgendwie so ein großes Ding
bei diesem Kongress einfach so die anderen Dinge,
die auch noch so passieren.
Zum Beispiel einen Podcast aufnehmen.
Zwei meiner Highlights abseits von den Vorträgen sind mittlerweile seit mindestens letzten Jahren, teilweise auch schon länger.
Zum einen das Capture the Flag.
Da machen wir jetzt immer als Gruppe bei dem Junior Capture the Flag mit und auch nicht sehr erfolgreich.
Aber das macht einfach total Spaß, da so ein bisschen rumzufrickeln, gemeinsam irgendwie zu versuchen.
Was ich mir erklären muss, vielleicht?
Kannst du mal kurz zusammenfassen?
Also haben
halt irgendwie so ein Capture-the-Flag-Team,
ein deutsches, hat
hier Server irgendwie
aufgestellt und
da gibt es eine Seite und da sind
irgendwie so Hacking-Aufgaben,
irgendwie nach Kategorien,
also irgendwie gibt es zum Beispiel die Porn-Kategorie,
also P, B, N.
Mal kurz davor nachzufragen.
Da
kriegst du irgendwie eine Binary,
eine ausführbare Datei,
musst dann irgendwie
versuchen, da
ein String rauszuholen
oder ein Passwort
rauszuholen, dann hast du hinterher so einen Code
und gibst halt bei der Seite
einen da und dann hast du diese
Aufgabe gelöst und dann kriegst du dafür Punkte und
hinterher, je nach Team sozusagen,
wird das dann graded,
wo du dann stehst, sozusagen,
je nachdem, wie viele Aufgaben du da bewerfst.
Hat das einen Zeitfaktor eigentlich? Kann man das nur während des
Kongresses machen oder kann ich das auch
nächste Woche, wenn ich...
Das kannst du auch nächste Woche noch machen, aber das Rating
ist
vor einer Stunde
vorbei gewesen, gemacht.
Das heißt, ab jetzt ist
nur noch Spaß.
Und
genau, also das macht
auf jeden Fall voll
Spaß, finde ich. Das heißt, ich kann das morgen noch in Ruhe
einfach so... Genau, richtig, ja.
Und
das haben wir auch letztes Jahr schon gemacht,
ebenfalls nicht besonders erfolgreich, aber
Es ist einfach so schön, dass es da irgendwie so eine Junior-Variante gibt,
wo man sich das ein bisschen ausprobieren kann.
Was ist denn die Nicht-Junior-Variante?
Die ist einfach schwerer dann.
Mit schwereren Aufgaben.
Er ist ja auch noch ein ganz junger Typ, der Marius.
Also im Vergleich zu uns alten Säcken hier.
Wer weiß, ne?
Was übrigens auch sehr cool war, das finde ich auch irgendwie immer wieder zu schätzen am Kongress,
ist, dass es neben den
Talks und dem
früher genanntes Hackcenter
eigentlich
auch immer eine sehr geile Party gibt.
Wir beide
waren ja gestern Abend
im Disco-Drama, heißt es,
und
ich schrieb irgendwie Steiger, der hier rechts
neben mir sitzt, ob er nicht vorbeikommen will,
und dann schrieb er so, nö, kommt mal zu Chaos West,
da ist gerade alle Farben.
Und ich dachte mir so, what?
Geil.
Dadurch, dass das Gelände hier so weitläufig ist
und es nicht mehr auf mehreren Stockwerken stattfindet,
sondern man hier enorme Wegstrecken hinter sich bringt,
man hat es ehrlich gesagt für mich eher was von einem Indoor-Festival.
Ja, irgendwie schon.
Du hast genauso viel, du hast halt keine Zelte, du hast Assemblies,
aber die Leute sind bunt angezogen, alles leuchtet, jeder macht irgendwie einen drauf
und anstatt dass du zu irgendwelchen Bands gehst, gehst du zu Vorträgen.
Ja, genau.
Oder zu Bands.
Oder zu Bands, genau.
Und ich fand das auch gestern Abend total geil.
Wir laufen da rüber zu dieser Chaos-Westbühne,
wo der aufliegte.
Und du hast da irgendwie 100, 200 Leute,
die übel abgehen, die total Party machen.
Und du siehst das von Weitem.
Und 5 Meter nebendran sitzt einfach so eine Horde-Nerds
an so einer Assembly, ist total unbeeindruckt
und hackt, hackt.
Das sind diese Filter-Bubbles, von denen die Leute immer reden.
Ja, aber ich finde das geil hier.
Zu dem CTF wollte ich noch sagen,
da habe ich an meinem Tisch an der Chaoszone
SMD noch
neben mir zwei Leute sitzen, also
zwei Freunde, unter anderem auch
einen Junghacker, der noch
in die Altersspanne reinfällt, der auch
tatsächlich leider um
23 Uhr oder so aus dem Hotel sein muss und dann
seine Mutter anrufen muss, ja Mama, ich bin jetzt
im Hotel, danke, tschüss.
Und konnte
Samsrod nicht sehen, konnte Sonnebohr nicht sehen.
Du meinst, der geht mal kurz
raus und sagt, ich muss mal kurz
stille. Der ist da auch...
Ach, der muss vom Festnetz aus im Hotel anrufen?
Ja, quasi die Mutter ruft dann
wohl auf dem Festnetz im Hotel an oder sowas.
Also die hat da schon ein Verfahren, was da
schwer zu bekämpfen ist.
Ach, da hätte die Mutter doch einfach mitkommen können.
Ja, kann ich mir auch nicht so ganz erklären.
Auf jeden Fall.
Die Datentoilette getunnelt irgendwie so.
Diese beiden Freunde und dann
diese Junghacker, die machen das Junior-CTF
und deswegen werde ich jetzt auch nicht namentlich
sagen, weil natürlich wäre es dann ja
so einfach.
Und
habe dann wie so gehört, dass wir gestern Abend
angefangen haben mit der ersten Challenge und hatten die
halt nach drei Stunden gelöst, außer
dass halt so ein ganz kleiner
Bug war und den zu finden hat
dann ja ganz kurz gedauert, also bis jetzt
gerade eben. Also insgesamt
über einen Tag, aber halt
eigentlich war es in zwei Stunden gelöst, bis auf
dass da irgendwo mal wieder ein Sonderzeichnen-Code falsch war
und dann ist natürlich wieder alles anders. Aber so ist es
Besser für Entwicklung immer. Die letzten
5% brauchen nochmal genauso lange.
Das habe ich dann auch gesagt. Das ist doch eine wertvolle
Erfahrung, die unser jungen Hacker gleich
mitnehmen kann. Bist du sicher, dass du dir das
für dein Leben antun möchtest?
Wie mal ein alter Projektleiter
von mir immer so schön sagte, mach mal 80%,
aber bitte mit 20%
Effort.
Sehr gut.
Wie ist das für euch?
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das ist eher wie
so ein Camp jetzt gerade.
ich erwische mich so, teilweise gestern
haben wir diesen Film hier geguckt, All Creatures Welcome,
der noch irgendwie
da die Zeit in Hamburg
eher dargestellt hat.
Und ich habe mich so ein bisschen
dabei ertappt, dass ich mir gedacht habe,
eigentlich war es da ja
doch schon ein bisschen schöner.
Dieses Verwinkelte, dass du einfach irgendwo
bei Sachen auch zufällig vorbeigekommen bist,
das passiert jetzt nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr in dem Maße.
Da muss jemand schreiben, hier, da ist gerade
alle Farben zum Beispiel.
hier da hinten gibt es eine Spontan-Demo oder so.
Ja, fast alles irgendwie auf so einem Gang war,
weil du diese riesenbreiten,
ewig langen Gänge hattest,
bist du auch zwangsweise an viel mehr Sachen
einfach vorbeigekommen.
Also ich kenne Hamburg nur vom ersten Mal.
Die beiden Jahre danach hatte ich leider keine Zeit hinzugehen.
Es war fünf Jahre in Hamburg.
Bitte?
Nee, drei.
Nee, fünf.
29 bis 33.
Okay.
Es war eine bestimmte Zeit in Hamburg.
Doch.
Ich hatte gestern auch jemanden getroffen und dann ging es darum, welcher war denn der erste Kongress in Hamburg.
Das war tatsächlich der 29.
Und seit dem 34. sind wir jetzt wieder in Leipzig.
Oder jetzt erstmals in Leipzig.
Aber ich wollte eigentlich gerne an einer anderen Stelle einsteigen,
weil wir vorhin das Wort Filterbubble genommen haben und ich ja doch ein bisschen was von dem Rückblick machen möchte.
Stimmt.
steht hier als nächstes
nach dem Datenspun und dem Kongress
Cambridge Analytica und das hat ja auf jeden Fall
was mit
Filterbubbles zu tun.
Ist aber
jetzt nicht von mir der Punkt? Also vielleicht
kann mal irgendjemanden da drauf gesetzt hat.
Also ich habe
diesen Jahresrückblick angefangen und der fängt
bei Januar an und wir sitzen jetzt gerade bei
welchem Monat hast du das gefunden?
Jetzt waren wir gerade bei Dezember.
So.
wir könnten es jetzt chronologisch machen, das wäre mir fast
lieber. Ich habe auch sehr viele Themen hier drinnen
nur so
erwähnt oder
drauf geschrieben, falls jemand was dazu sagen könnte.
Ich meine,
ich weiß auch nicht, ob das jetzt
umfänglich so interessant ist, weil über Facebook
wurde jetzt so viel berichtet dieses Jahr.
Ich glaube, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht unbedingt
explizit nochmal dran erinnern, genauso wie ich jetzt auch
nicht über die DSGVO reden wollen würde.
Da wurde gefühlt
so vieles gesagt. Ich glaube, wir sollten uns
auf Themen begrenzen.
wo wir vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen was Sinnvolles
zu sagen können. Genau, aber ich meine, dieses Jahr
ist viel passiert. Also das Jahr fing
an mit den Veröffentlichungen
von Meltdown und Spectre. Dazu kann man sich auf
diesem Kongress nochmal ein, zwei Talks angucken, die
sehr viel tiefer reingehen.
Was mich überrascht hat, ist, dass es
mittlerweile irgendwie bis zu
zehn Meltdown
und Spectre-Varianten gibt.
Vor allem Spectre, ne?
Die dann Spectre, TK oder
was weiß ich heißen. Da gibt es sehr viele
gute Talks, auf die man hier eingehen kann. Das war Januar.
eine große Veränderung in der Welt,
wo eventuell Steiger ein Wort zu erzählen
könnte, ist, dass dieses Jahr das CoreOS
von Red Hat gekauft wurde.
Das, glaube ich, war ein ganz schöner
Paukenschlag.
Die Company ist ja auch eher bekannt
geworden dadurch, dass sie ein sehr kompaktes Linux
nur für Containereinsatz
eigentlich in die Welt
gesetzt hat. Das war aber
so ein Nebenbei-Projekt.
EdCD ist ja eigentlich so ein richtig
großes Softwareprojekt von
den sehr beliebt und
damit haben die sich im Prinzip
gemausert und jetzt kam auf einmal Red Hat
um die Ecke und hat gesagt, hier, wir kaufen
CoreOS. Ich glaube, da spielen
zwei Aspekte rein. Die waren ja
selbst mit ihrem Atomic nicht allzu erfolgreich
und
Core ist dagegen, also das
OS, war extrem beliebt
und
die hatten ja oder haben
mit OpenShift auch
ihre eigene Kubernetes
Distribution, den
fehlte, aber irgendwie auch ein schöner,
sinnvoller Mechanismus, dieses Ding
zu deployen. Und
diese ganzen schönen Bausteine,
die waren bei Core, ist schon alle da.
Na, die haben das auf jeden Fall mal sauber durchgezogen
und mal etwas
übersichtlicher, muss man sagen.
Und dann? Das war so, das war
im Januar passiert?
Nee, das war nicht im Januar.
Das war später.
War das nicht schon letzten Dezember?
Ich hab's, sagen wir es so, ich hab's
bei Heiser
Januar aus dem News-Tacker rausgezogen.
Ja, dann wird das, denke ich, stimmen.
Auf jeden Fall hatte ich dann so den Eindruck,
der Donnerschlag war noch nicht mal verhallt.
Man hörte ihn noch am Horizont.
Und dann kam IBM.
Und dann hat Red Hat jetzt gekauft.
Das wird vielleicht auch spannend
dann für nächstes Jahr werden.
Was wird Linux-mäßig?
Ich glaube, für das Linux-Ökosystem
wird das gar nicht so einen großen Einfluss haben.
Wo das, glaube ich, extrem spannend wird,
ist für das Java-Ökosystem.
Denn Reddit hat sich in den letzten Jahren auch im Java-Ökosystem an vielen Stellen eingekauft.
Denen gehören ganz viele Frameworks.
Oder was heißt gehört?
Ja, die entwickeln viele Frameworks.
Die haben ja eine eigene Application-Serve mit JBoss im Programm.
Und IBM ist in der gleichen Sparte, in der gleichen Ecke aktiv.
IBM hat darüber hinaus noch seine eigene JVM.
Also ich glaube, in dem Bereich wird es sehr viel Konsolidierung zum einen geben.
zwischen den Bereichen, wo es Überlappungen gibt.
Und zum anderen könnte das vielleicht auch ein interessanter Push
weg von Oracle werden, was die JVM als solches angeht.
Schauen wir mal, was passiert.
Eine Nachricht aus einem der Monate,
die ich jetzt gerade nicht wieder genau zuordnen kann,
weil ja, dass Java von Oracle demnächst nicht mehr kostenfrei zur Verfügung steht.
Das ist bereits der Fall, also Stand jetzt.
Also die Meldung ist ja...
Muss man für dieses Qualitätsprojekt jetzt zahlen?
Nein.
Java ist weiterhin frei verfügbar.
Der Punkt ist bei dieser Kostenpflichtigkeitssache,
dass du für ältere Java-Versionen, also Java 8 konkret,
war halt eigentlich End of Support gedacht.
Aber wie wir ja so Enterprise-Dopfer kennen,
ist das ja alles so ein bisschen behäbiger.
Enterprise heißt ja, wir nehmen das von vor 10 Jahren.
Rell hat ja auch so fünf Jahreszyklen, da ist jetzt irgendwie sieben, ist irgendwie 2014 oder so rausgekommen, jetzt steht langsam acht an und es gibt Firmen, die haben gerade von fünf auf sechs geupgradet.
Und bei Java ist es halt auch so ein bisschen, da sind wir jetzt eigentlich bei elf und acht ist halt eigentlich auch schon ziemlich alt und das will man eigentlich auch nicht weiter maintainen und deswegen werden die Updates da kostenpflichtig.
Da kommen verschiedene Sachen tatsächlich zusammen.
Also nach der 8.00 hat sich Oracle gesagt, weil die hatten in der Vergangenheit Riesenprobleme
mit der Entwicklung eines ganz konkreten Features des Modulsystems, das sinnvoll reinzubringen.
Und das hat in der Vergangenheit die letzten drei großen Releases, eigentlich 7, 8 und 9, ordentlich verzögert.
Und die haben sich gesagt, naja, wir verkürzen jetzt diese Release-Zyklen auf ein halbes Jahr.
Gleichzeitig wollten die aber auch mal so Schwänze abschneiden,
wie wir maintainen hier mehrere Releases gleichzeitig
und müssen die irgendwie supporten und können da kein Geld dran verdienen.
Also haben sie gesagt, na gut, dann verlangen wir da jetzt Geld dafür
und machen hier so einen LTS-Release-Zyklus und so ein Gedönse.
Was man dabei im Hinterkopf halten sollte, das betrifft Oracle-Java.
Java an und für sich ist Open Source, steht unter der GPL
und daran wird sich auch nichts ändern.
an diesem Entwicklungsprozess wird sich auch
nichts maßgeblich ändern.
Nur wenn du eben Oracles Distribution
verwenden möchtest, dann musst du zukünftig
für die Produktion Geld bezahlen.
Seit Java 11.
Das ist halt dann deine Abwägung.
Wenn du jetzt Geld bezahlst zu Oracle, damit du nicht
upgraden musst.
Du kannst ja auch auf JDK gehen.
Oder auf IBM.
Wenn du jetzt meinetwegen Oracle, Java haben wir jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Dann kannst du halt sagen, entweder ich
zahle jetzt die Kosten zu upgraden auf das
neuere oder ich zögere es jetzt halt raus und
dafür muss ich halt auch bezahlen in Form von
Geld an Oracle. Das ist halt eine Geschäftsabwägung.
Also ich sehe
diese Java-endlich-kostenpflichtig-Meldung
jetzt nicht so dramatisch,
auch wenn es natürlich eine schöne Headline ist.
Ja, das habt ihr aber sehr schön zusammengefasst,
weil ich mich an das Thema noch gar nicht eingelesen hatte,
was das genau bedeutet.
Ich habe tatsächlich vor drei Wochen
bei mir in der Firma einen
einstündigen Vortrag über dieses Thema
gehalten.
Mein Beileid.
Okay, dann sollten wir ganz schnell zu einem anderen Thema,
sonst geht es eine Stunde lang so weiter.
Das ist in vielen Projekten sehr, sehr unterschiedlich.
Okay, dann lass uns nicht mehr über Java reden.
Da wir noch jetzt gerade im August waren,
möchte ich jetzt hier noch eine Headline sagen,
die ich hier im August noch mir notiert hatte.
Einfach nur so völlig ohne weiteren Kontext.
Milania Trump mahnt mehr Anstand im Netz an.
Und was passiert?
Das Ding ist ja, also, das kann man ja,
diese Aussage, die kann man ja an sich nur unterschreiben.
es ist nur ein bisschen zynisch, dass sie von ihr
kommt.
Also sie selber
macht jetzt nicht so
groß um sich reden.
Das stimmt, ja.
Vielleicht war es ja auch tatsächlich als
Seitenhieb gegen ihren Mann gemeint.
Wahrscheinlich sollte sie eher mal ihrem Mann öfter mal
das Handy wegnehmen.
Sie hat sich ja auch irgendwie auf die Fahne geschrieben,
doch dachte ich irgendwie gegen
Mobbing im Internet da irgendwie so ein bisschen
aktiv zu sein. Da ist halt schade,
das ist irgendwie gefühlt das Einzige, was ich
dieses Jahr darüber gehört habe.
Wer weiß, was
ihr Mann tütern würde, wenn sie ihn nicht
ständig davon abhalten würde, was da noch alles kommen würde
Das, was wir von ihm so mitbekommen
sind vielleicht ein paar Momente, wo sie
ihn gerade mal nicht abhalten kann
Stell dir das mal vor
Ja, das liest man ja irgendwie öfter, dass es da
so einen ganzen Stab an Leuten gibt, die
versuchen ihn von seinem Handy fernzuhalten
So, jetzt habe ich aus Versehen
den Jahresrückblick von
politisierbar draus gemacht
Hier ist immer alles politisierbar
Naja, meine Liste ist jetzt auch
bei weitem nicht vollständig. Also man kann uns
definitiv vorbehaben, dass wir sehr viel ausgelassen haben.
Obwohl wir gerade bei Politisierer waren.
Oktober. Linus Torvalds nimmt eine Auszeit.
Ich wollte mich eigentlich jetzt
irgendwie wieder zurück zu Februar
durchkennen. Also im Februar habe ich
hier echt nicht viel stehen.
Im März
Verschlüsselung GCHQ
kritisiert die kommende TLS
Version. Dazu kann ich euch
nur noch empfehlen, schaut euch den Vortrag
über TLS 1.3 an.
Da kommt das alles ziemlich gut.
Der ist nämlich, glaube ich, im März verabschiedet worden.
Ich denke, da waren noch die Draft-Dressen draußen, also die Entwürfe.
Und ich hatte das auch eigentlich richtig eingestellt.
Der war im Moment im August, ist der verabschiedet worden.
Ich glaube, im Allgemeinen können wir, glaube ich, da rausziehen.
Also wenn ein Geheimdienst einen Kryptostandard kritisiert,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich ein gutes Zeichen.
Definitiv.
Also das war auch eher so das Prädikat,
besonders glaubwürdig,
wenn das GCHQ sagt,
bitte mach das mal nicht.
Besonders Upgrade-Bau.
Naja, die Folgen sehen wir jetzt in Australien,
um mal wieder zu springen,
die ja jetzt dieses Gesetz verabschiedet haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht wann,
aber es ist auch erst ein paar Wochen her,
dass ja jetzt Firmen,
die in Australien ein Geschäft machen wollen,
Daten auf Anfrage
dann auch entschlüsselt rausrücken
müssen, sonst hagelsfette
Strafen. Also ich hoffe nur,
dass das dafür
an die Regierung oder an den
Sicherheitsdienst, Geheimdienst rausrücken müssen.
Beides nehme ich an.
Ich habe es mir jetzt nicht im Detail angeguckt,
muss ich gestehen.
Es wurde aber in den Medien viel behandelt.
Also man
kann glaube ich nur hoffen,
dass es zur Folge hat,
dass Australien da zum gebrannten Kind der Branche wird.
Ja, also Australien leistet sich ja einiges gerade in letzter Zeit in der Richtung.
Ist so ein bisschen das Anti-Schweden quasi.
Ja, absolut. Die haben ja eine Zeit lang, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das noch machen,
haben sie in diesem Jahr angefangen, an der Grenze bei bestimmten Leuten
die Passwörter von den Social-Media-Konten zu erfragen.
Das finde ich schon richtig krass.
Ich dachte, das hat die USA sogar eingeführt.
Das weiß ich nicht genommen.
Da könnte ich mir schon eher...
Das meine ich auch, ja.
Da könnte ich es mir schon eher vorstellen, aber das...
Würdet ihr euer
Twitter-Passwort abgeben?
Das ist halt auch der Grund, warum ich nicht in die USA
einreisen werde, zumindest in der aktuellen
politischen Lage. Also ich hatte jetzt auch einen Bekannten,
der war in den USA und dann haben wir echt lange überlegt,
wie wir das jetzt eigentlich machen und sowas.
Und wir haben dann halt am Ende Fake-Identitäten uns aufgesetzt
als E-Mail-Adressen und
Und haben dann halt darüber Kontakt gehalten, falls er noch irgendwas brauchte oder falls sich was in der Wohnung irgendwie Blumen gießen soll oder so.
Und dann ist er halt mit einem frisch installierten Notebook mit so einem unauffälligen Windows 7 hingefahren, wo halt nicht groß irgendwas drauf war.
Und das ist dann irgendwie, er ist natürlich durchgewunken worden, weil er ein Tourist ist.
Aber die Paranoia ist dann wie schon da.
Und ich habe dann auch für mich persönlich so überlegt, was machst du denn jetzt, wenn du jetzt wirklich nicht willst, dass die Leute auf deine Social Media Accounts zugreifen.
was ja sowieso Quatsch ist, weil
die Five Eyes haben sowieso die
Abhörschnittstelle, wo sie einmal alles kriegen von Twitter
und abgesehen davon, dass
Twitter sowieso weitestgehend öffentlich ist.
Also was du auf Twitter schreibst, sollte eh öffentlich sein,
was du auf Twitter in Privatnachrichten schreibst,
ist auch nicht, da weißt du, dass es nicht so sicher ist
an und für sich. Ja, aber trotzdem möchte ich
mein Passwort da nicht abgeben.
Also schlimm wäre es, wenn sie wirklich nach deinen
E-Mail-Passwörtern oder sowas fragen.
Dann hätten sie dich wirklich beinahe.
Aber
überlegt man dann schon, ob man in so ein Land
in der gegebenen Situation noch einreisen möchte.
Die schwerwiegendere Frage ist eher, wenn die USA
das machen, wann fängt
dann eine deutsche Behörde an,
die Leute nach ihren Passwörtern zu fragen.
Wie wir gestern gelernt haben,
macht das Band das ja schon
mehr oder weniger. Genau, weil das sind
alles so kleine Schritte, die das immer mehr
in die Normalität rücken, solche Sachen.
Wir machen ja heutzutage Sachen,
wo du dir vor zehn Jahren noch gedacht hättest,
das ist so ein abgefahrener Scheiß,
Das würden wir noch niemals mit uns machen lassen.
Das ist heute wesentlich normaler geworden.
Und heute, wenn du in Deutschland einreisen möchtest
und nicht mit dem Flugzeug am Flughafen landest,
weil du Tourist bist oder Einwanderer aus einem westlichen Land,
sondern weil du aus einem eher östlich gelegenen Land nach Deutschland fließt,
darfst du dich einmal komplett nackig machen.
Und dann gehst du durch die gesamte Prüfung durch.
Dein Handy wird angeguckt, deine gesamten Dokumente werden durchgeguckt.
Und dann musst du ein Foto in einen Telefonhörer in deiner Landessprache beschreiben.
Und sie sagen dir, du klingst nicht, als ob du aus Syrien kommst.
Du kommst eher aus Ägypten.
Wir lehnen jetzt deinen Syriantrag ab.
Ein Rechtsstaat sollte man meiner Meinung nach auch daran messen, wie er mit den Schlechsten umgeht.
Da sieht man schon einige Defizite, würde ich sagen.
Was diesen Grenzübertritt angeht.
Ich meine, dass doch eines der ersten Projekte von Julian Assange
so ein Dateisystem war, glaube ich,
wo du irgendwie beim Entschlüsseln,
je nachdem, welchen Kilo angegeben hast,
hat er sozusagen was anderes entschlüsselt.
War das nicht sogar TrueCrypt?
Nee, das war Rubberhost FS.
Das war an sich auch eine gute Idee.
Du bist da an der Grenze.
die sagen, hier, gib mir mal ihr Passwort ein
und dann gibst du dein Passwort ein
und da ist, keine Ahnung,
Windows 7 und nicht dein normales
Arbeitslinux oder sowas.
Mit TrueCrypt kannst du dir aber, meine ich, sowas auch einrichten.
Das große Problem,
das du damit hast, ist aber
also dieses System,
das musst du ja dann schon auch
zumindest
ab und zu dann auch mal
in irgendeiner Form regelmäßig mal bespielen,
weil das wird ja
sonst auch keiner halbwegs sinnvollen
Analyse standhalten, wenn die da dieses
Systembooten sehen,
der hat sich da seit zwei Jahren nicht eingeloggt,
eigentlich auch nicht
das Ding gebootet gehabt,
dann werden die schon wissen, dass du
da mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit noch was anderes hast,
was du zu verbergen versuchst.
Also wie sehr dich sowas schützt,
ist immer diskutierbar. Es gibt schon länger
diese
Aussage,
wenn sie an deine Daten rankommen
wollen und dich haben,
dann kommen sie halt an deine Daten ran.
Das ist immer die Unterscheidung,
wenn sie dich eh schon nach deinem Passwort fragen können,
dann können sie dich auch ein zweites Mal
nach dem richtigen Passwort fragen.
Das ist total korrekt.
Die Idee dahinter ist ja aber,
dass du das nicht erkennen kannst
an dieser Festplatte,
dass da noch ein anderes System drauf ist.
Klar, wenn du es irgendwie dumm anstellst
und das vor Jahren mal eingerichtet hast
und dann nie wieder benutzt hast
und irgendwelche Timestamps von damals da drin sind.
An der Stelle wird es halt unglaublich wichtig,
dass du noch andere rechtsstaatliche
Mechanismen hast, die dich dann da irgendwie
schützen können. Und wenn wir mal
nach England gucken, die halten
dich an der Grenze fest und
möchten, dass du dein Passwort rausgibst
und du tust das nicht, dann können die dich
ja erstmal auch ziemlich lange festhalten.
Weil du das nicht rausrücken möchtest.
Und dann gucken wir mal nach Bayern
oder diese ganzen anderen neuen
Polizeigesetze.
Da wird das langsam auch brenzlig.
Dann musst du dein Passwort noch nicht rausrücken.
Aber das ist der nächste logische Schritt.
Ohne Frage, ja.
Apropos Standards, die sich verschoben haben,
da hatten wir auch einen interessanten Vortrag auf dem Kongress jetzt zu.
Das passt ja auch zum Jahresrückkriegsthema,
denn wir hatten dieses Jahr ja die Hausdurchsuchung
bei den Zwiebelfreunden und beim Chaos Augsburg.
Und da gab es einen Vortrag
Verhalten bei Hausdurchsuchungen,
praktische Hinweise für den Kontakt mit der Staatsmacht.
Und das ist so ein bisschen ein Update
für den zwölf Jahre alten Vortrag, glaube ich, mittlerweile...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, den Vortrag gab es schon mal, ne?
In der ersten Weile her, den habe ich irgendwann noch gesehen.
Von Hugo Fetter, Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen.
Genau, der Vortrag war ja von Kubi.
War jemand von euch dann da?
Also ich habe es nicht mehr in den Raum reingeschafft.
Da war doch sehr schnell sehr voll.
Nee.
Also ich war da, ja.
Also wie verhält man sich dann bei Hausdurchsuchen?
Ich habe gehört, dass es sehr gut war.
ich habe das mit besonderem Interesse
verfolgt, weil ich wurde ja vor
ein paar Wochen
jetzt zum Vorsitzenden des Chaos-Grupp-Grupp-Dresden
gewählt.
Ja, gut.
Also meine...
Ja.
Das war halt hauptsächlich so eine Sache von
Freiwillige vor und ich habe vergessen, zurückzutreten.
Wie immer.
Bei Vorstandsarbeiten.
Genau.
Das ist natürlich absolut nicht
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig.
und das Problem ist
dann natürlich auch, dann ist man ja im Zweifelsfall
derjenige, wo dann die Polizei klingelt,
wenn sie den Verein halt mit
irgendwelchen aus ihrer Sicht
illegalen Tätigkeiten im Zusammenhang sehen
und deswegen ist das natürlich
jetzt für mich interessant, da muss ich wahrscheinlich nochmal meine Obstück
verbessern, also zum Beispiel die
ich habe noch keine Anwaltshandynummer bei mir um den Portemonnaie
Kann dir da jemanden
in Berlin empfehlen?
Ich hatte das Problem
ja kürzlich
Ja, in Dresden brauche ich ja jemanden am besten.
Ja, das steht auf meiner Liste für nächstes Jahr.
Was haben sie gesagt?
Also natürlich schön alle Festplatten verschlüsseln.
Backups haben natürlich auch Offsite-Backups,
weil was natürlich auf einer Festplatte in der Schublade liegt,
das hilft natürlich nichts, weil die nehmen sie auch mit.
Ja, jein.
Ja gut, wenn sie dumm sind, natürlich nicht.
Also es gab ja diese Anekdote,
dass jemand, dass eine Hausdurchsuchung gemacht wurde,
das sollte ein PC mitgenommen werden.
und dann war es aber so ein iMac
und der Polizist hat dann im Protokoll
gemerkt, da stand nur ein Monitor und eine Tastatur.
Das ist optimal.
Da war kein Rechner.
Oder ich mache ihm dann den Computer mal aus,
Sie wollen den ja mitnehmen.
Du, es gab auch die,
es gab auch angeblich
Hausdurchsuchen, wo der Rechner dann quasi lief
und dann hat der Polizist dann zum
Durchsuchten gesagt, fahren Sie den bitte mal runter,
damit wir den mitnehmen können. Genau. Sehr gerne.
Man muss dann,
Gut, man muss vielleicht aufpassen, dass man da nicht plötzlich überraschend kooperativ ist an der Stelle.
Weil natürlich, man muss zu jedem Nein sagen.
Also auch irgendwie, ja, Polizei steht da, wir wollen rein.
Ich möchte jetzt erstmal den Schluss sehen.
Guckst du dir den Schluss an? Jetzt wollen wir rein.
Ich möchte erstmal meine Kopie ausgehändigt haben.
Da haben sie vielleicht die dann tatsächlich auch dabei.
Jetzt wollen wir rein.
Ich möchte erstmal mit meinem Anwalt sprechen.
So, jetzt wollen wir aber rein.
Dann kannst du halt noch sagen, also ja.
Kann auch noch Zeugen hinzuziehen.
Genau, lassen Sie uns jetzt rein.
Da musst du halt trotzdem Nein sagen, weil ansonsten ist es ja ein Einverständnis.
Dann kannst du sowieso nichts mehr dagegen machen, sondern musst du halt trotzdem Nein sagen.
Das ist sowas wie Nein, aber Sie haben einen Beschluss, also werden Sie jetzt reingehen.
Gibt es eigentlich ein Update?
Weil ich kann mich noch an den zwölf Jahre alten Vortrag erinnern.
Und da hieß es ja, dass Anwalt und Zeuge keine aufschiebende Wirkung hat.
Also man kann dann anrufen, aber die würden dann in der Zwischenzeit trotzdem schon beginnen,
bevor der Anwalt vor Ort ist.
Und auch der Zeuge muss jetzt, das weiß ich aber nicht, ich bin ja kein Anwalt, deswegen frage ich gerade.
Ich bin tatsächlich auch kein Anwalt.
Oder wie?
Im Vortrag.
Also da habe ich auch schon irgendwie ein bisschen widersprüchliche Aussagen zugehört.
Das scheint mir etwas so ein Grauzonen-Bereich zu sein sozusagen.
Das Ding ist de facto, wenn die reingehen, kannst du halt wenig gegen machen.
Naja, wenn du dich halt jetzt wieder setzt, dann ist es halt auch wieder gleich ein Straftat bestanden.
Widerstand gegen die Staatsgewalt und das ist auch
nicht ratsam.
Ja, also
ich hätte mir diesen Talk ja auch
sehr gerne angehört. Wie gesagt, ich bin
da nicht reingekommen, habe mir gedacht, gut,
dann esse ich was und höre mir
den mal im Stream an.
Ja, ich war ja
selbst von dieser Hausdurchsuchung
also bei den Zwiebelfreunden
betroffen, so als ehemaliger
Vorstand, den sie
da irgendwie mit reingezogen
haben, weil ich eben noch
Kontozugriff hatte.
Du bist derjenige, der Mo erwähnt hatte,
den Mo erwähnt hatte, der
irgendwann mal mit dieser Kontofollmacht
noch irgendwo eingetragen war. Genau
derjenige bin ich.
Ja, war ganz
spannend. Ich war nämlich
im Urlaub in Schottland,
als die da eingeritten sind.
Das heißt, ich kam aus dem Urlaub
nach Hause irgendwie
abends
sowieso schon anderthalb Stunden
Verspätung gehabt irgendwie durch den Flug.
Willst eigentlich nur noch
in Ruhe was essen, duschen und dann schlafen.
Und dann machst du so den Briefkasten
auf und hast so einen Durchsuchungsbefehl
und so einen handgeschriebenen Zettel so
ja komm mal hier und da auf die Polizeiwache
deinen neuen Haustürschlüssel abholen.
Dann ist dir so, what?
Also du bist nicht mal reingekommen in deine eigene Wohnung?
Nee, ich bin nicht mal reingekommen in meine Wohnung.
Haben die Schloss denn aufgebaut oder wie?
Ja, also die haben wohl zuerst irgendwie versucht
die Tür aufzurammen oder so.
War wohl wenig erfolgreich.
also man sieht auch an der Tür, dass es wenig erfolgreich war
und dann haben sie sich einen Schlüsseldienst
geholt und das aufbauen lassen
haben irgendwie meinen Nachbarn rausgeklingelt
da morgens um 5
um den als Zeugen da mit reinzunehmen
ja
genau und dann
morgens um 5 war ich?
das ist immer morgens, weil du ja nicht vorbereitet
sein sollst, sollst ja nicht bei der Sache
sein, sondern dann können sie einfach
machen, wenn du das so
wobei ich das in Berlin, also bei mir
Gegenüber auch schon mal nachmittags gesehen habt,
da haben sie wohl irgendwelche Krönpflanzen gesucht
auf dem Balkon.
Bei all die Hobbybotaniker.
Ja, genau, die Hobbybotaniker.
Bei denen gehen sie wahrscheinlich davon aus,
dass die früh um fünf noch wach sind.
Möglich, ja.
Oder auch nachmittags um vier
nicht voll da sind.
Auch möglich, ja.
Nee, und dann, also
hast du diesen Wisch dann erstmal irgendwie
das Gepäck bei einem Nachbarn abgestellt?
und dann wackelst du davor zur Polizei
und liest ja dieses Ding noch zwei, drei Mal durch
und dann steht halt, ja, nach Paragraph
so und so wurde bla bla bla bla
dann guckst du erstmal nach
welcher Paragraph war das jetzt, bin ich
beschuldigt irgendwas
oder bin ich das jetzt nicht und dann denkst du so
als Zeuge
okay, jetzt wird es
absurd, ne und
erstmal Schlüssel geholt, unterwegs dann
irgendwie versucht die anderen mal anzurufen
und ich dachte mir so, ja, Zwiebelfreunde
rufst du mal Moritz an.
Moritz erreichst du nicht.
Das ist ja jetzt blöd.
Juris probiert so. Ja, Juris erreichst du jetzt auch nicht.
Das ist aber auch blöd.
Dann denke ich ja so, scheiße.
Irgendwie mal so Torservice
Notfallhotline angerufen.
Auch niemand
rangehört. Scheiße, wie erreichst du die denn jetzt?
Schöne Notfallhotline.
Ja, klar.
Was ich ja in dem Moment nicht wusste,
bei denen waren sie ja logischerweise
auch und da haben sie natürlich dann noch die
Handys konfisziert.
Das heißt, das hat dann irgendwo eine Asservatenkammer gekriegt?
Das hat dann wahrscheinlich irgendwo eine Asservatenkammer gekriegt.
Also die haben Handys auch inklusive SIM-Karten.
Ja, ja, klar.
Ja, genau.
Und dann
habe ich irgendwie überlegt,
wen kannst du da jetzt anrufen,
um mal irgendwie an ein bisschen Kontext zu kommen.
Dann habe ich mich
daran erinnert, ja komm hier,
Mo, war doch irgendwie Open Lab.
Guckst du mal beim Open Lab auf der Webseite,
ob da irgendwie von irgendjemandem irgendeine Telefonnummer steht.
Siehe da, die haben so eine schöne Kontaktseite,
wo irgendwie Handynummern von zwei Vorstandsmitgliedern draufstehen,
den Erstbesten angerufen, so,
Hi, wir kennen uns nicht, wir haben uns noch nie getroffen,
ich müsste mal mit Mo reden.
Geht's um eine Hausdurchsuchung?
Ja, woher weißt du das?
Ja, die waren auch bei uns.
Ah, okay.
Ach ja, da kommt übrigens auch gerade Mo.
Ja, und dann da irgendwie erstmal ein bisschen Kontext abgeholt.
Das klang irgendwie alles ganz skurril.
Und dann nahm das so seinen Lauf.
Dann braucht ja jeder seinen eigenen Strafrechtsanwalt.
Auch jede Organisation, die durchsucht wurde, braucht ihren eigenen Strafrechtsanwalt.
Du kannst ja also nicht als Gruppe dann irgendwie einen holen.
Da haben wir dann irgendwie das Open Lab hatten Anwalt, Zwiebefreunde hatten Anwalt,
jeder, der durchsucht wurde, hatten Anwalt.
dann gab es bestimmt noch irgendeinen Anwalt.
Koordinieren die sich dann miteinander, die Anwälte?
Jein.
Also wir haben das
ein bisschen versucht, das zu
streuen.
Ist das nicht sogar eher zu deinem Vordergrund?
Wir sind auch...
Ja, es geht halt darum,
dass jeder da sein eigenes
Verfahren hat.
Also wir sind da auch...
Das fand ich dann ganz spannend.
Das wurde nämlich dann...
Urteilsbegründung, als das Ganze dann für illegal dann auch erklärt wurde, das war das Landgericht an München, die haben quasi die Fälle dann auch zusammengefasst sozusagen und daraus wurde dann auch schön ersichtlich, dass eigentlich auch jeder Anwalt da eine ganz andere Strategie gefahren hat, also sprich, das Gericht hat ja dann auch einfach
eine Heidenarbeit damit, einfach schon mal damit umzugehen,
dass sie da auf die verschiedensten Aspekte der verschiedenen Strategien der Anwälte da eingehen müssen.
Ich, was ich ja sehr interessant fand in diesem, es gab da ein Urteil, was gezeigt wurde,
zumindest wo Ausschnitte zitiert wurden und da wurde sowas,
also ich kann natürlich diese juristischen Postwählen jetzt nicht zitieren aus dem Kopf,
aber so quasi die angeordneten Maßnahmen waren außerhalb des Rahmens der Strafprozessordnung oder sowas.
Und da hat uns dann halt die Anwältin, die Frau Pietrik, die da mit dem Vortrag war, mit erklärt, dass es so quasi juristendeutsch, dass das Landgericht zum Amtsgericht sagt, haben Sie ja nicht Ihre Juristenexamen aus dem Kaugumiautomaten geholt?
Das war eine ganz schöne Watsche. Ich muss auch sagen, der Anwalt, den ich mir da gesucht hatte in Berlin, ich war mit dem Mann am Ende auch hochzufrieden.
Ich legte dem diesen Durchsuchungsbefehl durch. Das Ding war mega kurz, das war so eine halbe Seite oder so.
Er hat sich das durchgelesen, hat ganz irritiert geguckt, nochmal umgeblättert, das nochmal durchgelesen,
guckte hoch und sagte dann so ganz irritiert, also das ist interessant.
Und das meine ich jetzt alles andere als positiv.
Ich legte das so leicht angewidert zur Seite und erzählte dann so,
das wird nicht lange Bestand haben in diesem System.
Aber wie war die Situation dann für dich an der Stelle?
Du bist dann irgendwann am nächsten Tag erst in deine Wohnung reingekommen?
Nee, ich bin da dann abends noch reingekommen.
Ich bin ja dann direkt zur Polizei, konnte mir den neuen Schlüssel direkt mitnehmen.
Das war stressfrei.
Da gehst du zur Polizei.
Ich war ja auch nichts beschuldigt, deswegen stand da auch keine Gefahr.
Haben sie irgendwie deine Wohnung durchsucht?
Ja, sie haben die Wohnung durchsucht, haben da natürlich irgendwie Computerfestplatten,
alle möglichen Kram, die sie gefunden haben, mitgenommen.
Sie haben meine externe Festplatte gefunden, die ich seit einem Dreivierteljahr selbst schon gesucht habe.
Das fand ich ziemlich gut.
Ja, also man muss sagen, sie haben auch irgendwie alle möglichen Papierkram mitgenommen.
Die Konten, mein Zügelfreund, sind bei der GLS-Bank.
Von daher haben sie alles mitgenommen, was auf die GLS-Bank hindeutete.
In meiner Zeugenbefragung später wurde ich dann auch darauf angesprochen,
ob ich selbst zufällig noch ein Konto bei der GLS-Bank habe oder hatte,
weil die Unterlagen haben sie auch mitgenommen.
Da stand halt GLS-Bank drauf.
Ist ja auch sehr schwer, so Adressen zu lesen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also, man kann positiv hervorheben, es sah danach noch halbwegs ordentlich aus in der Wohnung.
Also, ich hatte schon so Horrorszenarien ausgemalt, wie es in der Wohnung aussehen könnte.
Das war zum Glück alles nicht der Fall.
Also, es war irgendwie so halbwegs in Ordnung.
Irgendwie, was ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen konnte,
also zumindest im ersten Moment so, nachdem das Ganze dann beendet war,
Da hat das dann auch Sinn ergeben.
Du kommst so in die Wohnung rein, guckst dich um, siehst so, hä?
In einer Ecke, da stehen doch noch zwei alte Computer.
Wieso haben sie die nicht mitgenommen?
Wirklich nicht so, als wären sie vielleicht noch benutzt.
Ja, waren sie auch tatsächlich seit langem nicht.
Das ist natürlich eine Strategie.
Einfach die eigene Computing-Technik verlottert aussehen
und dann einen unbenutzten Billig-PC daneben stehen haben,
der aber schick aussieht.
Immer abends die ganzen Kabel abziehen und daneben stellen.
Oder den eigenen Rechner in den alten Commodore 64-Gehäuse verstecken.
Genau.
Ich hatte da eben auch zwei alte Sunworkstations in der Ecke stehen.
Dafür sind die ganzen Defekt-Aufkleber, die hier überall rumliegen, doch super praktisch.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr on the nose.
Oder kein Urinal, wie es jetzt immer gibt.
Im Übrigen zu dem Punkt, sie haben auch
wegverlorene Sachen wiedergefunden.
Es war dann auch natürlich die Frage
gekommen, auch schon antizipiert
worden in dem Vortrag, hilft es denn
irgendwas zu verstecken? Und da meinten
sie, nee, nee, nee, weil
wenn die jetzt der Meinung sind, dass sie irgendwas
finden wollen, dann suchen sie halt, egal ob das
da ist oder nicht. Und wenn sie halt jetzt
ihr kriminalistisches
Gespür, was ja sehr
ausgeprägt war auch in dem Fall,
wenn sie jetzt halt glauben, dass sie eine externe
Festplatte suchen, dann suchen sie die halt. Und wenn sie
dann suchen sie halt trotzdem und
als ein krasses Beispiel wurde dann genannt,
dass irgendwie auch mal eine Wand durchbrochen wurde,
um in einen Raum zu gelangen, obwohl es
dort eigentlich noch eine offene Tür gab.
What?
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Also da habe ich auch schon verschiedenste
Geschichten gehört
von solchen Aktionen.
So, ich will jetzt
natürlich nicht komplett abbrechen
an der Stelle, aber ich würde mal gerne
ein bisschen weiter mit dem Jahresrückblick
vorankommen wollen.
Gibt es da was Positives?
Ja, naja, ich nähe eigentlich zwei Sachen, wo man so geteilter Meinung sein kann.
Das Erste, ich glaube, das ist weniger diskussionswürdig, Cloudflare betreibt ja jetzt einen Public DNS.
Der ist tatsächlich am 1. April, am 1.4. mit der Adresse 4xD1 an den Start gegangen.
1.1.1.
Genau, 1.1.1 oder 1.001, in Kurzschreitweise nur noch 1.1.
Also da kann man schon was sparen.
und Mozilla hat sich dann darauf auch eingelassen und wollte jetzt in Firefox diesen DNS-Dienst
über das neue DNS über HTTPS-Protokoll standardmäßig aktivieren.
Da hatte ich dann noch so den Eindruck, dass sie sich da so ein bisschen verhoben haben
und den Bevormundungsfaktor an der Stelle etwas unterschätzt haben.
Sie haben quasi den DNS-Server im Browser hart vorgegeben, wie ich mich an sich erinnere.
Genau, also man hat im Prinzip die Möglichkeit, das normale DNS-System so zu nutzen, wie es ist.
Oder zu sagen, der Browser soll über HTTPS Cloudflare-Server anfragen.
Der macht dann exakt genau einmal eine Anfrage per DNS, um herauszubekommen, wo der Cloudflare-Server steht.
Beziehungsweise bei Cloudflare weiß man die IP, die wäre dann hart eingekodiert.
Und wird er im Anschluss nur noch über HTTPS mit dem Server sprechen.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass niemand mehr sieht, welche Server ich ansurfe und welche Server aufgelöst werden sollen.
Hat aber auch den Nachteil, dass alles dann genau über diese eine Firma geht.
Das ist ein US-amerikanisches Unternehmen und da hat man natürlich dann wieder das Five Eyes Problem,
dass dort die Daten abgegriffen werden sollten.
Ja, das ist nur die Frage, ob ich dem einen Server dort, der wohl implementiert ist und bei Cloudflare steht, mehr vertraue
oder davon ausgehe, dass irgendeiner, der mir von meinem ISP zugeordnet wird, schon richtig sein würde?
Ja, also das ist immer noch so eine konkrete Frage, weil vielleicht will ich ja dasselbe System nutzen,
denn DNS über HTTPS ist auf jeden Fall spannend.
Ja, da hängt aber, finde ich, auch wieder ein Stück weit so die Frage dran.
Also es hat Vorteile, klar, das sehe ich auch.
HTTPS ist auch von der Implementierung her ein sehr, sehr komplexes Protokoll.
Und die Komplexität von DNS, die ist Stand heute auch nicht zu vernachlässigen.
Und du baust dir da halt einen gigantisch komplexen Haufen Code zusammen.
Ja, ich glaube noch nicht mal das ist das Problem, sondern es geht halt einfach darum,
dass sich ja auch Verfahrensweisen dann ändern.
Also zwei Dinge, die mir jetzt direkt einfallen,
ist zum Beispiel,
logge ich mich irgendwo in einem Gast-WLAN ein.
Meinetwegen bei der Bahn oder so.
Wenn du zu Hause bist,
kannst du das vollständig unter Kontrolle
beziehungsweise kannst du einfach deine Fritzbox konfigurieren.
Wenn du jetzt woanders bist,
dann musst du es schon in deinem Betriebsthemen konfiguriert haben
beziehungsweise wenn dein Browser das überhaupt berücksichtigt.
Das macht, glaube ich, Firefox nicht mal unbedingt.
Nee, eben.
Und wenn ich jetzt in so ein Hotspot-System mich einloggen möchte,
da weiß ich auch nicht unbedingt die Adresse des Portals,
wo ich mich dann einloggen muss.
Und das ist natürlich dann recht problematisch.
Also ich denke, da gehen auch ein paar Semantiken verloren.
Auf jeden Fall finde ich es trotzdem sehr spannend.
Also ich denke, das ist ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Echt? Also würde ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht sagen.
Wir haben irgendwie mit dem DNS mal einmal ein System,
was irgendwie weltweit dezentral ist
und wo jeder irgendwie auch gerne seinen eigenen DNS-Verfahren benutzen kann.
Ja, richtig.
Und dann da in so einem Browser irgendwie fest eine einzelne Organisation reinzuschreiben,
ist absolut das Falsche.
Nein, nein, da hast du mich jetzt falsch verstanden.
Ich meine natürlich, dass das Protokoll zur Erneuerung ist.
Aber auch da gibt es doch DNS-Sec.
Das müssen wir einfach mal irgendwie ein bisschen flächendeckender benutzen.
Es sind ja auch zwei verschiedene Dinge.
DNS-Sec sagt einfach nur, dass die Antwort authentisch ist.
die wurde nicht geändert.
Trotzdem kann jeder reinschauen.
Und dafür gibt es dann DNS
über HTTPS oder über TLS.
Und das, sage ich, ist erstmal eine gute Entwicklung.
Also das DNS-Protokoll allgemein
ein bisschen sicherer zu machen an der Stelle.
Natürlich ist es eine ganz gefährliche Sache zu sagen,
wir geben das jetzt in irgendeine Institution
oder in eine Unternehmung rein,
die das dann exklusiv machen soll.
Halte ich für kritisch.
Genauso kritisch wie dann zum Beispiel
solche Seiten, in denen noch gewesen sind,
wie der Webserver, den ich anfrage,
der schickt mir gleich mal die IP-Adressen
der Server, wo ich jetzt noch
irgendwelche Schriftarten oder so runterladen soll
oder meinen Browser runterladen soll,
alles gleich mit. Das halte ich für
eine kritische Sache,
aber auch interessant. Also das wird
auf jeden Fall... Ich meine, prinzipiell ist das spannend
insofern, als wenn du die Seite
einmal angefragt hast,
warum soll sie dir dann nicht auch noch die IP-Adressen
von den anderen Ressourcen geben?
Das ist natürlich heutzutage nicht mehr wirklich applikabel in der Welt
DNs. Aber ich meine,
der DNS, den du am wenigsten
vertrauen kannst, leider ist der
von deinem ISP, weil der, je nachdem,
in welchem Land du bist, wird der halt entweder
was zensiert oder manipuliert
oder beobachtet.
Das konnten wir ja
vor ein paar Jahren schon bei der Deutschen Telekom
beobachten, die dann auch
angefangen hat, per Default
DNS
zu injecten, wenn du irgendeine Domain
eingegeben hast, die sie spontan nicht
gefunden haben und sich dann auf die Telekom eigene
Suche umgewerfen hat.
Genau, die hat dieses komische Spaß-Feature,
dass sie sich auf so eine Suchseite umgeleitet haben.
Völlig unpraktikabel.
Nun ja, und das zweite,
das ist vielleicht auch noch ein Punkt,
die hier die Gemüter
ein bisschen mehr bewegen würde.
GitHub wurde gekauft.
Tatsächlich, genau. Also wir hatten die Geschichte,
dass CoreOS wurde von
Red Hat gekauft und Red Hat von IBM,
aber mittlerweile gehört
GitHub Microsoft.
Dann stelle ich da jetzt mal so eine ganz kontroverse These auf.
Also ich meine, so ganz an und für sich finde ich so diese Zentralisierung des Internets ganz allgemein eher scheiße.
Aber GitHub von Microsoft gekauft, muss ich sagen, also es hätte wesentlich schlimmer kommen können.
Finde ich erstmal so gut.
Also ich fand die Entwicklung auch nicht so schlecht.
Ich muss sagen, Microsoft hat in den letzten Jahren relativ viel in dieser Open Source Software Welt gemacht.
Sie sind vorher schon auf GitHub einer der größten, also eine Organisation mit den größten Contributions gewesen.
Und ich finde es an und für sich konsequent, dass sie es gemacht haben.
Ich hätte es schlimmer gefunden, wenn GitHub von Google gekauft worden wäre zum Beispiel.
Ja, da sind wir uns, denke ich, eigentlich.
Und mit den anderen Projekten, die sie so in letzter Zeit am Start haben,
hat Microsoft da eigentlich schon relativ viel Bewegung in die richtige Richtung gezeigt.
Das machen immer noch Windows, aber das ist mittlerweile eher so ein Nebendings.
Ja, du kannst glaube ich auch heute mit einem Betriebssystem nicht mehr großartig Geld verdienen.
Der Markt verschiebt sich immer mehr in Richtung Services.
Microsoft hat das erkannt und die entwickeln sich sehr, sehr stark in Richtung,
wir möchten gute Services, gute Tools für Entwickler bauen.
Und da passt GitHub gut in das Portfolio rein.
Und sie lassen das ja auch Stand heute erstmal als eigene Unit laufen, beziehungsweise der Kauf ist ja auch noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Das muss ja erstmal noch genügend werden.
Erstmal ein Jahr lang weiter als eigene Unit laufen.
Genau, aber sie wollen das ja auch als eigene Unit weiter laufen lassen, von daher warum nicht.
Ich finde das Thema gar nicht so unbedingt kontrovers.
Spannender fand ich in dem Zusammenhang eher, dass Microsoft gesagt hat, ja wir bauen hier unseren eigenen Browser, aber wisst ihr was, das ist jetzt gar nicht mehr so ertragreich, wir stellen den jetzt ein und machen jetzt den nächsten Edge auf Basis von Chromium.
Das finde ich bedenklich irgendwie.
Das ist so auf einer technologischen Ebene bedenklich,
aber wenn man sich mal anguckt, in welcher Position Microsoft ist,
das ist eigentlich sehr konsequent.
Sie sind nämlich momentan, gerade nachdem sie GitHub gekauft haben,
im Besitz der zwei größten Projekte,
oder zumindest der zwei größten Editoren, die auf Electron basieren,
nämlich mit Atom und VS Code.
Atom gehörte zu GitHub.
Achso, stimmt.
Unter diesem Aspekt habe ich das tatsächlich noch gar nicht betrachtet.
Und es wäre eigentlich nur konsequent,
wenn der nächste Edge einfach eine Elektron-Anwendung wäre.
Ja, aber in dem Sinne auch eine Webkit-basierte oder Chromium-basierte Anwendung.
Das wird eine Chromium-basierte Anwendung.
Nee, aber ich muss mich da anschließen.
Das ist eigentlich bedenklich, weil der Punkt ist,
wir hatten vor vielen Jahren die Browser Wars,
wo ein Internet Explorer dann am Ende als Sieger hervorgegangen ist.
Die ersten Browser Wars.
Ja, die ersten Browser Wars.
Und danach hatten wir so mitbekommen, dass die Technologie dann sich sehr Richtung Microsoft verschoben hat,
was ja nicht wirklich gut war für das Web.
Ja, vor allem hin zu proprietärer Standards.
Genau, und jetzt haben wir unseren Sieg-Ping-Chrom an der gleichen Stelle
und alle springen auf diese Engine, auf diesen Browser-Core zurück.
Und dann liest man zum Beispiel sowas wie,
Microsoft hat in dem Edge irgendwie Video-Hardware-Beschleunigung eingebaut.
Die war wohl sehr, sehr gut.
Also mit dem Laptop unterwegs stundenlang Videos anschauen
und in YouTube wurde dann explizit dort ein Element eingefügt,
das war nicht zu sehen, Sinnhaftigkeit muss hinterfragt werden,
hat aber die Hardware-Beschränkung deaktiviert.
Das möchte ich jetzt erstmal nicht unterstellen,
dass das absichtlich da eingebaut wurde wegen Edge.
Also man weiß es einfach nicht, man wird es auch nie erfahren.
Also ich schätze, die Entwicklung in den Webstandards
wird sich in den nächsten Jahren schon nochmal einiges verschieben.
Also diese Geschichte mit Standards und offenen Standards.
Und so ist es ja momentan schon längst nicht mehr so,
wie wir das aus den ersten Browser Wars kennen.
In den ersten Browser Wars war es so, es gab das W3C,
die haben den Standard definiert, wie soll HTML aussehen.
Das war allerdings nur HTML und CSS.
JavaScript war zu dem Zeitpunkt, glaube ich, noch überhaupt nicht standardisiert.
Und jeder Browser hat so einigermaßen das gemacht,
was Netscape vorgegeben hatte.
Und alle haben sich beschwert,
dass Microsoft in den Internet Explorer Sachen eingebaut hat,
die nicht standardisiert waren.
dementsprechenden Seiten im Internet Explorer besser aussahen.
Und muss man dazu sagen, ein paar von den Sachen, die sie bei sich eingebaut hatten,
waren schon relativ innovativ.
Sie haben zum Beispiel ganz krasse Grafikeffekte über CSS möglich gemacht,
die die Yamain-Browser nicht konnten.
Zum Beispiel der XMHTTP-Request ist ja auch vom Internet Explorer erfunden worden,
was dann die Basis für Ajax war.
Genau. Und jetzt, heutzutage hast du keinen W3C-Standard mehr.
Einige Firmen haben sich sogar aus diesem Konsortium zurückgezogen,
sondern du hast die WOT, die Web, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, Working Group.
Du hast den sogenannten Living Standard.
Das heißt, es läuft eher ab, dass die Browser-Vendors was implementieren
und das dann so nachträglich als Standard vorschlagen.
Und sobald es mehrere Implementierungen gibt, wird es zum Standard deklariert.
Genau. Ich glaube auch der nächste Kampf-Schauplatz da wird nicht,
wie das in den ersten Browser war, die Darstellungsschicht sein.
sondern die Protokollebene
viel eher, weil da kannst du
Bandbreite sparen, das sind die
großen Kostenfaktoren
Das ist das, wo Google Innovationen macht
Genau, da macht Google
Ja, aber das ist auch, finde ich, alles
sehr, sehr bedenklich
weil auch
durch diese, also klar
es bringt ihnen was, aber
sie
forcieren das
sehr, sehr stark, also gehen auch mit der
Brechstange rein und
du hast halt auch wieder diesen Effekt,
du hast ein Google, du hast ein Amazon, du hast
Microsoft und ein Cloud-Fam
mit ihren riesen CDNs
und die bauen die Infrastruktur, stand
heute, und die bauen diese Infrastruktur
für sich und für ihre Clouds.
Und diese anderen Infrastrukturanbieter,
die kommen immer stärker ins Hintertreffen.
Umso stärker du die Protokolle
dann auch in Hardware reinkriegst,
desto stärker kannst
du auch diese Konkurrenten weiter aus dem
Markt rausdrücken und auf
Cloud standardisieren
oder monopolisieren.
Das sollte man tatsächlich im Auge behalten.
Was die Browser-Engines angeht, ist es
tatsächlich schade, dass Edge wegfällt, obwohl es
tatsächlich die meisten Leute
eher benutzt haben,
um Chrome damit runterzuladen.
Ansonsten war die Verbreitung
eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich
gegeben.
Was so die Engines angeht,
sehe ich das eher so, dass bei Chrome
arbeiten tatsächlich ja auch Mozilla-Mitarbeiter
mit an der Engine, zum Beispiel an
Web-RTC-Implementierung, die in Chrome drin ist,
die an vielen Stellen verwendet wird.
Also ich sehe, dass
die Entwicklung
von den Browsern eher so ein bisschen wie beim
Linux-Körner. Momentan ist die,
ist es einfach nicht mehr möglich.
Das wird mehr Commodity werden.
Momentan ist es einfach nicht so, dass
jemand, und das finde ich krass, dass Microsoft
mit Edge das überhaupt geschafft hat, dass jemand
hinkommt und eine komplett frische
Browser-Engine-Implementierung
irgendwo hinstellt.
Das ist auch nur Internet Explorer, aber aufgeräumt.
Also viel alten Scheiß rausgeworfen,
kurz mal rausgeworfen,
ActiveX, tralala.
Aber es wird zumindest keiner mehr jetzt hinkommen und sagen,
pass auf, wir bauen jetzt mal einen komplett neuen Browser.
Bis zum Beispiel Mozilla
Server weit genug ist,
die haben noch sehr, sehr viele Checkboxen
zu checken.
Und deswegen sehe ich eher so,
dass... Ich finde, man sollte da zum Abschluss
einfach sagen... Deswegen sehe ich eher so,
dass dann viele in den nächsten Jahren
an Chromium einfach mitarbeiten werden.
Und wenn wir in 20 Jahren von Browsern reden, werden wahrscheinlich
die meisten auf Chromium basieren, aber alle
werden an Chromium mitarbeiten, so wird es wahrscheinlich
aussehen. Leute, benutzt mehr
Firefox. Genau, ich bin
dauerhafter Firefox-Nutzer
und ich kann es nur empfehlen. Kann so unterschreiben.
Mittlerweile wie so ein
gallisches Dorf, wenn man das benutzt.
TreeStyle Tabs for the win.
Ja, genau.
So, wir haben jetzt hier das Problem, dass wir jetzt einen Sideslot haben,
denn die nächsten, also sie schienen noch nicht bereit,
aber ich kann sie schon quasi fast
so fühlen, dass wir gleich in den Nacken
atmen. Das ist ja ein Problem, was wir
sonst bei Akronomisierbar nicht haben, bei
Penta Radio schon, aber bei Akronomisierbar ja nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich hier schon
die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen signalisiert
und auch Hendrik hat auch signalisiert, aber dann
verquatscht man sich natürlich wieder,
denn wir wollen ja gerne noch über zwei andere
Sachen reden. Das eine ist, was ich
im Vorgespräch gehört habe, ist, dass Hendrik
in einer Session war
namens Podcast der Selbstkritik.
Erzähl mal.
Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, schaut euch die Aufzeichnung
dazu an. Das war eine Runde von
dem Stefan Schulze
vom Aufwachen-Podcast
und der
Nikolas Wörr von Methodisch Inkorrekt war
dabei und den dritten
muss ich sagen, konnte ich nicht wirklich einordnen
und dann gab es einen vierten Platz, der immer
frei war für Gäste und dann sind aus dem Publikum
immer mal andere Podcaster
aufgestanden und haben sich mal kurz für ein kurzes Statement
dazugesetzt und es
wurde so ein bisschen diskutiert, das war hauptsächlich
aus der Perspektive von deutschen Podcasts
wie
das so und wie findet das
Publikum das? Das Publikum konnte auf so einem Board
mitschreiben und Meinungen reinfließen lassen
und es ging vornehmlich darum
Finanzierung und Format
es war durchaus
spannend, ich kann es gar nicht wirklich wiedergeben, aber
die Finanzierungsebene war
allgemeiner Konsens im Groben
war, die Leute wollen alle keine Werbung
es ist auch komisch, wenn die Leute Werbung selber
vorlesen oder einspielen
es gibt allerdings auch Podcasts, die eine Dreiviertelstunde lang
die Namen ihrer Spender vorlesen, was
auch irgendwie seltsam ist, ich möchte auch
Leute irgendwie nicht um Geld spenden, bitten müssen,
aber wenn ich hier irgendwie, ich bin auch, ich persönlich
bin auch kein Vollzeit-Podcaster,
das merkt man irgendwie an der
Kadenz, an dem Intervall, in dem
so eine akronisierbare Folge immer rauskommt.
Im Büro heißt ja auch nicht St. Oberholz.
Eben.
Ich meine, wenn du halt den Aufwachen-Podcast machst, wie halt
Stefan Schulz und Thilo Jung und
der Herr Jessen,
dessen Vornamen ich jetzt vergessen habe,
spontan, die machen ja
jede Woche zwei Sendungen
und die sind so vier, fünf Stunden lang
muss dann natürlich proportional vorbereitet werden,
weil die ja auch Nachrichtenclips spielen.
Das ist ja Nachrichten-Review quasi.
Und das heißt ja,
das ist ja allein schon so quasi
eine halbe Stelle quasi.
Das Geld muss ja irgendwo herkommen.
Also außer du machst das halt wirklich
außer wir kriegen, dann musst du zu Grundeinkommen.
Aber da haben wir jetzt leider selber
nur begrenzten Einfluss drauf.
Wie lange hast du denn, also ich meine,
wir haben jetzt hier diese schöne Themenliste,
die wir also zum großen Teil ignoriert haben.
Wie lange hast du denn
für die Vorbereitungen gebraucht.
Weil ich meine,
das ist ja jetzt keine redaktionelle Vorbereitung
in dem Sinne.
Nee, es ist auch nicht wirklich redaktionell.
Das Format von uns ist ja auch wirklich,
wir treffen uns und schauen mal, was passiert.
Aber die Zeit und der finanzielle Aufwand ist schon da.
Also das Hosting kostet Geld.
Die Lizenz für Reaper würde theoretisch Geld kosten.
Und für eine Stunde akronomisierbar
verbringe ich nochmal anderthalb Stunden
irgendwie dann das Nachteil nochmal zu hören,
die Qualität nochmal ein bisschen zu verbessern,
mein ganzes Geräuschbau rauszuschneiden.
Das ist furchtbar, ja.
Ja, ganz schlimm.
Aber ich
mache das ja auch zum Spaß, aber wenn jemand das Vollzeit
macht, ist das eine andere Frage. Also einer der Punkte,
die ich in dieser
Runde
an das Wort geschrieben hatte, was überhaupt nicht
erwähnt wurde, fand ich, man könnte doch
diesen Rundfunkbeitrag abzwacken.
Also ich wohne seit diesem Jahr zum ersten Mal
alleine,
in einer eigenen Wohnung und ich habe jetzt Ende des Jahres
zum ersten Mal den Rundfunkbeitrag
für ein Jahr komplett alleine bezahlt
und es waren 190 Euro.
Wenn man mal guckt, das sind 17 Euro im Monat.
Das kostet,
das ist mehr als ein Netflix-Abo
und zwar das Gute,
das ist mehr als Spotify
und das BBC nimmt nicht
so viel Geld ein und macht ein besseres Programm
als das öffentlich-rechtliche. Jetzt ist die Frage,
könnte man nicht irgendwie vielleicht beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
mal Geld beantragen? Guck mal, ich bin ein Podcaster
Ich habe 10.000 Zuhörer und ich möchte bisher etwas Wirtschaftsförderung oder Podcast-Kulturförderung vom Staat.
Warum denn nicht so was?
Ich glaube, eine BBC ist auch wesentlich kleiner als unser deutsches öffentlich-rechtliches System.
Wenn ich mal gucke, wir haben irgendwie einen NDR, einen NDR, einen WDR, einen RBB und hast du nicht gesehen, wie sie alle heißen.
Und die haben dann alle nochmal irgendwie drei bis fünf Radiosender neben ihrem Fernsehprogramm.
Das ist schon ganz schön krass, was wir da stellen.
Das ist schon ein Haufen Holz.
Was ich nur mega schade daran finde, wenn ich eine BBC daneben halte,
die produzieren einen Haufen eigenen Content, der auch richtig geil ist zum Teil.
Die haben Teamsendungen im Radio.
Und wenn ich mir unsere deutschen Radiosender so angucke,
also ich komme ja aus Süddeutschland, da hast du irgendwie den SWR und den Bayerischen Rundfunk.
SWR 1, BR 1 wahrscheinlich, ist ja exakt das Gleiche in grün.
dann hast du noch diesen Volksmusiksender und den
etwas moderneren Sender.
Und die spielen, also das
Programm ist bei diesen Sendern
exakt gleich
aus meiner Wartesonung.
Aber das sind halt unterschiedliche Leute,
die das Programm machen.
Da brauche ich nicht zwei unterschiedliche Sender.
Was wahrscheinlich auch helfen würde,
wäre, also das frage ich mich ja
persönlich, wie würde der Rundfunkbeitrag eigentlich in der Höhe
sein, wenn wir keine Sportgrußveranstaltungen
auf dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen hätten, wenn das einfach
ATL laufen würde. Ich meine, das ist natürlich
jetzt, man kann mir natürlich jetzt vorwerfen, dass ich
gebeißt bin, weil ich bin einfach kein Sportgucker,
deswegen ist es auch egal, ob das
bei ATL läuft und dann irgendwie 20 Werbeinblendungen
dazwischen sind. Ich sag mal so, das ist ja
finde ich auch davon abhängig, was das für ein Sport
ist, also
Aha, inwiefern? Naja, also
sowas, also ich
Jetzt haben wir es geschafft, jetzt haben wir fünf Minuten vor Ende
ein richtig geiles Pass aufgemacht und das müssen
wir langsam leider wirklich
Ich finde das auch ein schwieriges
Thema insgesamt, auch Olympia und so
weil ich meine, das Geld versickert ja
im Zweifel sonst wo, ja.
Aber gerade so Fußball
oder sowas. Warum muss
ich das im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen zeigen?
Es gibt ein riesen öffentliches Interesse an Fußball.
Auch nicht von
mir, aber trotzdem
ist öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk
dafür.
Lass uns nicht mehr über Fußball reden.
Das ist ein Thema für ein ganz anderes Mal.
Der Kongress geht noch exakt einen Tag.
Wenn wir mal kurz von jedem noch einmal kurz, was schaut ihr euch
morgen an?
Security Nightmares.
Oh ja. Auf jeden Fall.
Infrastrukturbericht dann,
kurz vor der Plowsing Session, ist auf jeden Fall
für mich sehr gut.
Irgendwas davon.
Ich sage
stattdessen noch was, was ich
richtig cool fand
bei dem Kongress noch. Das eine ist
der CC Choir.
Der CCC Choir. Den habe ich verpasst.
Den gab es schon letztes Jahr.
Da haben wir ein Lied gesungen.
Dieses Jahr haben wir noch ein Lied gesungen.
Du singst auch noch mit. Genau.
Sehr gut.
Ich finde auch solche Sachen
passieren hier. Es gab
vorhin leider einen Flashmob, der jetzt
leider in diese Zeit reingefallen ist.
Das heißt, den haben wir verpasst.
Schade. Und das zweite,
es gab
unglaublich viele richtig coole
Talks über
Organisationen hier,
die sich mittlerweile
irgendwie, würde ich sagen, verstetigt haben.
die einfach unsere digitalen
Grundrechte schützen und das fand ich
richtig cool, also einfach so
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz,
die GFF hier, Gesellschaft
für Freiheitsrechte
und der
Landefeld
Vortrag hier,
das ist der Typ vom
DE-Kicks,
gehört. Es gab einen Vortrag
von Uwe
Lübbermann von
Premium Cola, der hat über
Ja, der war richtig gut.
Da war ich Kameramann dabei.
Ich werde morgen nochmal eine Runde hier drehen,
weil ich habe längst noch nicht jede Ecke gesehen.
Und wir werden offenbar, wir müssen nächstes Jahr
bei Akronomisierbar nochmal über alle anderen Sachen reden.
Sag mal noch schnell, was ich mir angucken werde.
Ich werde mir angucken,
Kernel Tracing with eBPF und Distributed DHCP.
Weil ich will mal noch ein paar Tech-Themen hören.
Du musst natürlich noch die gnadenlose Selbstpromo machen.
Gar nicht so einfach.
Bindestrich Podcast.de
ist mein Podcast.
Echt? Im iTunes oder so einfach suchen nach
gar nicht so einfach. Ich habe ein Foto gemacht.
Anhören mit super
Production Value. Das ist wesentlich
aufwendiger für wesentlich weniger Zeit.
Da hast du 10 Minuten folgen.
Da habe ich 5 Stunden dran gearbeitet jeweils.
Habe ich völlig vergessen. Siehste mal.
Also gar nicht so einfach.
Bindestrich podcast.de
Zwischen gar nicht so einfach keine Zeichen mehr.
Gut, damit haben wir das glaube ich
ziemlich gut zusammengefasst. Bevor wir jetzt hier
mit Gewalt rausgeschmissen werden und sich andere
den Stream mit einmischen. Vielen lieben Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit. Vielen Dank an Marius,
Stefan, Juhl und Steiger, dass
ihr mit dabei wart bei dieser Sonderfolge
Akronomisierbar. Vielen Dank vor allem euch Zuhörern,
gerade auf dem Livestream und auf den Sofas
nebenan. Hat mich sehr gefreut für
das Interesse.
Und ja, ich hoffe, wir sehen uns
alle auf dem Kongress nochmal. Dieses Jahr,
nächstes Jahr,
habt ein
sehr schönes
2019.
Bis dann.
Der nächste Folge in meinem Podcatcher beginnt in 3, 2, 1.